that [ __ ] actually like that life was
kind of like what the mobster dudes my
dad grew up in chicago
he said he knew like was in a
neighborhood like that and it was true
like no one said [ __ ] to the cops it was
just very like
you didn't say [ __ ] it was just you
didn't see nothing you didn't know
nothing mobs just kind of took care of
the community obviously they were
criminals too and would [ __ ] you up so
they would control everything yeah they
would extort [ __ ] obviously it
wasn't like all
great robin hood [ __ ] but like kind of
part of me is like that's sick that like
dope you just got people there needs to
be accountability obviously but it's
kind of nice that people just mind their
[ __ ]
i would have been so good at that [ __ ]
though i would have i would have denied
evidence so [ __ ] well it'll be
ridiculous like somebody would get shot
right in front of me a cop was standing
right there he's like you see that i'm
like see what
and i walk right over the body what are
you talking about you step on the crime
scene see that kid right there
see that little slant-eye [ __ ] that
[ __ ] kid did it he's a [ __ ] kid
yeah see that little [ __ ] noodle
eater give me some [ __ ] kids
i like him little gobble [ __ ]
don't witness nothing you know why
because his eyes are always closed
forget about it right what are you
talking about huh i would just never
see anything at all crime happens right
did you see that
i slammed it i can't see [ __ ] it's the
blanket that just the mob loves
but they think you're dope but you're
actually
that kid blind never ratted on [ __ ]
any of us he's like running in the walls
he doesn't see [ __ ]
like sonny that kid's blind he's like i
don't know what the [ __ ] you're talking
about
you're like damn right he's blind i know
that kids never [ __ ]
ratted on nobody excuse me sir i don't
see nothing
i was like yeah you're damn straight
there's a bowler here's a bowl of
noodles get the [ __ ] out of it
but i don't see the noodles this kid's
[ __ ] good
they're good it's [ __ ] amazing we
call that pasta in my neighborhood
that would be such a dope movie it's
about this kid that becomes like the top
mobster yeah just because he was
literally blind and he didn't see
anything he didn't see [ __ ]
and now he runs the mop and he's
confused he doesn't understand what's
happening
what is [ __ ] going on yeah you keep
playing dumb there
gabba and he's asian he's asian he runs
italian
but he's asian dude that's a [ __ ] oh
that's funny
that's
you did the korean l.a riot thing now
you go back to the 60s and yeah
it's time for the one blind korean kid
that joined the mobsters because
i don't see nothing i don't think that i
i never see anything right okay and he
rises to the top bang bang bang
every single scene is just me staring
off into the distance and people dying
around me yeah exactly
i just don't know what's going on i'm
sitting on piles of body
oh this is seen a little warm why does
it seem so hot
i don't understand where am i dude hell
yeah
that david park kid is a [ __ ] genius
that guy that's what i'll be saying
i'm just a witness in the stands like
what did you see i keep telling you i
don't see nothing
i see brock i said yeah
i [ __ ] love this kid
oh that's the perfect film dude that's
crazy oh somebody [ __ ] backed that
film
yeah dude start a gofundme and they're
gonna they're gonna uh produce it
gotta get the funds and gobble [ __ ] too
good electric boogaloo
electric bugger there's an electric
that's what it is
i think i think we're good at making
films i think i think so too yeah
that's a solid idea do you do you think
that if you were born in the 60s like
back in the day right that you could
join
like one of those mobs easy no just
because of how much stuff that they were
getting away with and how much power
that they had that's true because it was
different i felt like
rules are different i'd probably say
they are for sure um
i think like if i grew a poor in one of
those neighborhoods it would have been
hard not to like get into that life
but i mean i feel like well i don't know
i don't know how i would have been but
like [ __ ] people up like really badly
i would have felt i
i personally like at this moment would
have felt guilty about that but
i think i don't know bro i think you'd
be fine i think you could do probably
like running like some boogie [ __ ] like
some gambling stuff i could see myself
definitely doing that oh this the kid
with just
the [ __ ] the little french hat the
french hat with the tweed jacket just
running around
yeah they're doing errands for everybody
yeah yeah i can see myself doing that
i don't think i forgot your mail mister
i didn't forget my mail
no you forgot your mail he's like i got
his wallet
and you guys run yeah yeah done easy
[ __ ]
i'll be doing that at the age of 40 just
doing the same [ __ ] as a paperboy
hey mister you're 40. i'm 13. it's like
all right mister
just start passing up [ __ ] [ __ ] dude you
know we should talk about we should talk
about the [ __ ]
wayfarer conspiracy what's up with that
[ __ ] dude that came out of nowhere
this is so weird so i guess this kind of
developed either on reddit or a 4chan
something right
or i think it was reddit though but uh
wayfair
they were having certain items on there
with names of people
that were going on for an exorbitant
amount of prices
like cabinets like a metal cabinet that
you see it like and it was like
stacey maxwell or something yeah stacy
maxwell fourteen thousand dollars
sorry fourteen ninety nine and so you
know obviously with
conspiracy theorists they they kind of
go off in their own thing and so they
were looking up some of these names of
people
like i don't know somebody was like
named like samir or something like that
and it was a missing person
oh and they're like okay well this is a
little odd and they started looking up a
few other items
and they were connected to missing
people as well first and last name
whoa which is a little weird and so uh
wafer obviously denied it saying like
no this these are industrial grade like
fireproof whatever type of cabinets they
look regular but these are actually
priced appropriately